[Music]
it was a big day for movie news we got a
new teaser for Deadpool - not on my
watch mother and a seriously magical
music video for John Legend and Ariana
Grande's Beauty and the Beast
[Music]
back to Deadpool we see Wade Wilson up
to his usual antics he spots a man being
robbed and bolts for a phone booth to do
a quick change
brace yourself we see more Deadpool than
we bargained for Wow nice suit also pay
attention to that graffiti Nathan
summers coming soon a nod to the
character cable who will appear in the
highly anticipated sequel oh Jesus
oh that's not good what is good is the
new Beauty and the Beast music video not
only do we see John Legend and ariana
grande in regal movie themed attire we
see Belle and the piece enjoying a
romantic dance
[Music]
[Music]
et was with legend at the film's
premiere last week he gushed over being
able to revive the iconic song we're
happy to do this song an original film
original song and for us to be able to
recreate it's been fun
[Music]
you